police in the u.s say two officers have
been
shot and wounded during racial justice
protests in the city of louisville
demonstrations erupted across the
country after it was announced that
police would face
no charges for killing black woman
brianna taylor in march the mayor of
louisville taylor's hometown
has declared a curfew for the next three
nights taylor was shot dead when police
raided her apartment on a so-called
no knock warrant one officer has been
charged but only with endangering
taylor's neighbours not with her murder
her killing was one of several deaths of
black people at the hands of police
that set off months of anti-racism
protests in the united states
well our correspondent stefan simons is
standing by for us in louisville
kentucky
stefan protests are being held in cities
across the u.s but you're in taylor's
hometown where she was killed what's
been happening there
yeah looking behind me you wouldn't
believe what uh was the picture here
just hours ago
now we're here at the impromptu memorial
or
vigil for rihanna taylor here at uh
jefferson
park square here in downtown louisville
and hours ago this place was packed was
packed with protesters was also packed
with police with law enforcement
hundreds of them and what happened was
the
protesters took off this place here
in marches throughout the town police
followed this it immediately came to
scuffles after
the grand jury announced that there
won't be any charges
no arrests no charges filed against any
of those officers who were involved in
shooting riona brianna taylor six times
to death after that
what happened 46 arrests also i think
this is number increased there were more
arrests later on
as well as two police officers actually
got shot they are
in hospital one is as we understand
still in surgery but
both officers are not
suffering from wounds which are
endangering their lives we're told
and of course police now is asking for
help public help and finding
finding more out about who shot them
they have one suspect in custody
stefan elaborate for us if you will a
little bit about this decision that
sparked these
protests why were none of the officers
charged with murder or even manslaughter
excellent question and i don't have a
easy or simple answer for you because
i don't know law
experts don't know the the the attorney
of the taylor family uh it doesn't
really know and had to succumb to saying
like
this is a total disgrace this decision
the attorney general of the
state kentucky here said he followed the
law the state law and there was no room
and no space
allowing him to charge any of those
officers directly
and that is key here directly to the
death of briona
taylor that's why we only have a charge
of
um endangerment in the first degree
and three counts of this for one officer
the other two
weren't even charged there is literally
no charge against
any of the law enforcement involved in
the death of brianna taylor
and of course this is not sitting well
with anybody here people are actually at
an
absolute loss how this can happen and no
justice no peace
this is what we heard all day long this
is what we're gonna and we will hear
this for the next few days
and nights not only here in louisville
kentucky i'm sure about that
all right not the end of this story then
stefan simon standing by five for us in
louisville thanks very much for the
update
you